this question here doesn't get fries to
you like this quite I actually lead you
in a little bit okay but being that I
expect most of you did this maybe a
couple of days ago or something like
that I want to present it like this
because this is total fair game okay the
textbook leads you into this but if you
look at this question and stare it long
enough you shouldn't need a medium ok
have a look at it you can clearly see
that this is something to do with
binomial right because remember when you
get a real assessment it doesn't tell
you doesn't have a big red flag saying
this is what topic this is ok it will
just say he go good luck right now it's
a binomial I know it's a binomial
because look there are two terms and
I've got another two terms right but
clearly there's something a little more
going on ok so how do I take what I know
from binomial and Link it to this hmm
there are things being cubed over here
ok so I'm gonna need to cube something
that thing alive hand side x first one
and X it's all I know ok so I'm gonna
take that and I'm going to keep it ok so
I've cubed both sides so far so good
yeah now I know what to do with this i
can simplify this using what I know from
binomial theorem ok so this guy here I'm
going to have a pattern of 1331 those my
coefficients ok and because my first
term is x it's going to start with an X
cubed right and then they're going to go
x squared X to the 1 X to the 0 they're
going to climb up whereas these guys are
going to climb sorry all the way around
he's going to climb down three to 10 and
these are going to climb up okay so my
coefficients already set a 1331 so I've
got my three in here I'll have my x
squared it's highly down and then I've
got one of the other one right whatever
X is that a care to see how I'm building
this right if you do not feel
comfortable doing them all out what's in
your head like I said before writing
down your coefficients first and then
just fit everything in with the car
that's that one that's X to the 1 i'm
just writing the one so that i can
clarify for myself the pattern that's
happening this is going to become
squared and then my last one 133 I've
just got one and it's going to be this
guy raises a part 3 okay so there's my
patent this is all looking good that was
just the left hand side by the way I
cube both sides of this equation so this
is equal to 8 yeah McKenna this looks
good this looks really good because I've
got my X cubed stick right and I've got
my one on X cubed tick okay so this is
in the right direction right these are
clues you can use to think I'm just kind
of going blindly am I going blindly in
the right direction or in my own helpful
direction this is looking good what's
happening in here okay well I have three
of these and as an x squared or 1 and X
so how many x's do I have just one right
in here I've got the reverse situation I
still have three of them but I've got an
X here and I'm dividing by two of them
so let it have while on earth okay now
look this is really good because I've
done x I don't wander over X I've got
the same number of them and I know what
x + 1 x is equal to write so i've got x
cubed I've got three lots of x plus one
on X use whatever pieces you've got as
best as you can plus one on X cubed and
that's all equal to wait I'm pretty much
there now can you see so I've got my X
cubed I've got my one on X cubed and
then this guy which is six three times
two all right so come back ok so these
questions are really good one if you
look at this on the face of it's kind of
like where do I even go with this right
and the answer is we'll try and go
somewhere right try and use the little
that you know for to get from here to
here I clearly must raise the tire of
three and then see where it takes you
and what you how you can use what you're
reading